[Music]
[Applause]
well you light up a room I got a say in
incident I'm an energetic person cause I
am look at this everybody it is good to
have you here you got a fantastic thank
you man I dropped in on you in the
dressing room just before the show this
guy is in amazing shape I'm gonna say
that right now most of it I got a little
pervy there for a second but you love it
it's okay though you are in terrific
shape would you go to the gym constantly
don't I try to go man at least five or
six days a week Conan uh you know right
now working on my trophy that's what I
call my body Oh No right now I'm in I'm
in shape but you know when you get
involved with certain things you you you
take a loving to it like a certain type
of love and for me I get addicted so
right now I'm just addicted go we're
going to the gym with running just being
in shape but generally we got a picture
of you and it's in this is real this is
you in the clothes the outfit that you
wear to the gym yeah yeah what the hell
is going on here what are you wearing
what is that this is real how's the ball
that is a dry fit running outfit which
wicks the moisture from my body
now see here's the thing I don't know if
you guys can tell but I'm dark skin so
when I when I when I running nighttime
I'm afraid cuz I don't want to get hit
so what I do is I find bright colors
from the gym that's called my
highlighter running out very good
that's a terrific idea I am the opposite
I don't have to I can wear dark clothing
people see this face shining like the
moon and the whitest man in the world I
can do whatever I want no you don't have
to I do man I get lost at nighttime but
I've never been hit in that outfit
what's with the way who hurts with the
tights oh those tights yeah those those
are it's actually a form of a leotard
that's a one-piece coning you see I quit
I put shorts over the one piece you got
to step into that yeah and they only
make those in two tees that's a to
toddler for those who don't know that's
uh it's a it's a grown man babies Jim
now you are not just a very athletic
person yourself you're friends with a
lot of athletes
I am I am well you're hanging out with
you're hanging out with Shaquille O'Neal
I know I'm ah man you you go down the
list you know these guys like to be
around me because of my physical
attributes yes I motivate these guys to
do the right thing
Shaq is one of my closer friends man
knowing the big fella for quite some
time I relationship took a turn for the
worse
not too long back because Shaq has a
habit of picking me up in front of my
kids and I don't like it I don't like it
one bit because you know first of all
I'm a dad first you understand respect
me as a father so when I'm disciplining
my kids and I'm yelling but I'm done
don't turn around and grab me and shake
me
because you're taking away what I just
did yes yeah it's very hard for me to go
back and say sit down to my head yeah
with Shaq is telling me to do the same I
don't like it and I stopped talking to
him for a while I said you're gonna stop
doing it and he started scratching my
back and it felt good so I'll and he's
good at that he's a funny guy man he's
funny he has the same we literally had
the same conversation every time you see
each other now his whole thing is the
movie business like you know now he's in
a he's got grown-ups too coming out yet
so he started to be he's starting to get
into movies he's pitching me the same
movie his pitch meet wins the big and
black version that's what he calls it
where you to play twins yes we played
twins but here's a funny thing when he
pitches it he says now listen I'm gonna
be the Arnold Schwarzenegger and you're
gonna be today me DeVito as if it could
have been the opposite
[Laughter]
you felt that you had to point out
little words to me said he really wants
you to make this movie he really wants
to do it before we see that movie I bet
you they would see that movie into this
stuff make that movie no producers to me
like you will see me get picked up every
damn day I just want a piece of it
that's all